before computers and digital cameras
movies were edited by hand editors would
get rows of raw film and physically cut
and paste the scenes together this
process was called splicing but what
does this old editing technique have to
do with human disease it runs in the
family
chances are you've heard this phrase
before today we know that the biological
details from our bodies I passed out for
my parents this includes physical traits
like your hair color or height but also
your susceptibility to certain kinds of
disease all this information is encoded
in your DNA DNA is made up of four
nucleotide bases a G C and T and spell
out the information in the cell needs to
carry out the functions of life these
are organized into units called genes
now every cell in your body contains
workers called ribosomes ribosomes build
proteins and each protein carries out a
specific task in the cell
however ribosomes need instructions
every time they put together a protein
inside every cell there's a nucleus and
inside every nucleus there's a copy of
your DNA think of the nucleus as a media
center it produces tutorials that teach
ribosomes how to build proteins and
right now we need to build a protein to
strengthen the walls of the nucleus
we'll call it protein X imagine your DNA
is a strip of film from here to here is
one gene inside this gene is the whole
tutorial for building protein X but how
do we make the tutorial first the
nucleus copies this gene this copy is
called RNA and can be read by the
ribosome the original DNA
stays in the nucleus and is preserved
for future reference
but the tutorial is not ready yet
because the footage is scattered around
the gene
part of it is here another part is here
another part is here these frames of
footage are called exons the filmstrip
also contains frames that aren't part of
the video these sequences are called
introns and will not be in the final
tutorial one of their purposes is to
provide instructions on how and where to
edit the film this is the spliceosome
think of it as a film editor
it follows directions in the introns
cuts them out and pastes the exons
together this entire process is known as
splicing now we have a coherent tutorial
video that can be related to the
ribosomes splicing is crucial to the
correct construction of proteins
unfortunately mistakes can occur as a
result of mutations mutations are
variations from the nucleotide sequences
in our original DNA we used to think
only mutations and the movie frames
themselves caused disease but now we
know that mutations that affect the
splicing process can also cause disease
back to protein X if there are no
mutations in the film protein X will
look like this and fit perfectly into
the structure but let's say there's a
mutation in the film frames this might
cause protein X to have a little hole in
it like this when it slots in it leaves
a gap in the wall and you get a slightly
weaker structure now let's say there's a
splicing mutation a mutation and the
instructional frames this will cause the
organization of the video to be altered
some scenes might be missing others
might be cut short and others may
include unnecessary segments of film
this will have a much bigger effect on
how protein X is built the finished
protein might have an entire region
missing like this keep in mind that this
is happening in many cells at once so
imagine the kinds of damage that
splicing mutations can do
so why is splicing important experts
estimate that one third of all heritable
disease involves an error in splicing
still we don't have a detailed
understanding of how exactly splicing
goes wrong part of the problem is that
each person has about 3 million unique
differences in their DNA so it's hard to
tell which ones caused disease today
researchers are using computers and
statistics to comb through mountains of
mutations and model their effects on
splicing we hope to find patterns that
tell us how splicing is directed
eventually doctors may be able to come
up with personalized treatments by
studying the mutations that affect how
our genetic tutorials are edited